foreign
scrutiny committee I'm councilor John
Hinton and I'm chairing the meeting
today
my first dream of all remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern gov app
like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
council members of the council members
of the public and press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
medicine
the governor's office will just uh this
the extra members if you like that we
have here for this meeting today
thank you chair in attendance today we
have Fiona Duhamel director of
environment and Commercial Partnerships
Sarah Gilson parking services manager
Andrew wilcook SRP operations manager
Rebecca Hewitt corporate manager of
finance and operations Amy Mays share
the revenues partnership operations
manager Nigel delee shed legal service
business partner and general option as
the deputy monitoring officer and we
also have Jessica Fleming as the cabinet
member for environment
can I move to the agenda please
item one apologies for absence and
substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies from
councilor Melanie Barrett councilor
Catherine Grandin councilor Adrian
Osborne and councilor Sean Dawson and we
also have councilor Sue heirs and
councilor Derek Davis substituting
excuse me chair and also we have an
apology for councilor Dawson
to receive Declarations of pecuni other
registered registerable or
non-registerable interests by members
yes
um I have seek these advice regards
option uh agenda item eight council tax
I have been advised that my as my
um trying to work out working again I do
apologize been advised that the scheme
only applies for those who have to
declare earnings as my therapeutic
earnings do not apply I will not be
affected by risk scheme
thank you
Council Davis yeah I've been advised
that as I was on the cabinet when the
parking strategy review was first um
floated that I should leave the chamber
for that item
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
Jos stroke 22 stroke 7 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 27th
of June sounds like a long time ago now
doesn't it
1922 are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
I'm gonna have a proposal please
second and seconder so cancer scarf
the governance officer will conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair that rate is now in
progress cancer may I take your vote
please
and Council agency can I take your vote
please
Chancellor Ayers may take you quite
verbally please
we go
chair that is six foot and three
abstentions that's carried
for the minutes of the meeting of the
27th of June have been confirmed
questions by the public
move on to item seven Jos stroke 22
stroke eight baber and mid-suffolk
District council's parking strategy
again
I'd like to now invite the cabinet
member for environment to introduce the
report to the committee Council femi
hmm thank you thank you very much for
this opportunity to introduce the um
parking strategy for
um
baber and lit Suffolk which is a
document designed to cover the period
from the present 2022 end of to 2042 so
quite a long period of time
this
this work is the result of a very
comprehensive
period of consultation and stakeholder
engagement taking place over the past
year
it includes an online survey which
attracted over 2 000 respondents which
is very high
and a series of Road shows and meetings
with towns and Parish councils in both
districts these are summarized on page
14 of the report and the the
consultation process and the data
Gathering are summarized in appendix a
which I'm sure everyone has had a look
at and I think this is a very
comprehensive appendix and it shows the
degree of detail and effort that's
that's behind this the council engaged a
consultancy to support the work and to
bring some national expertise we had the
support of 2020 consultancy led by a
gentleman called Edward sir Adam Burns
and he has provided a lot of really
sound good advice he's been out to the
district and come with us to the
meetings
we've also used a current DFT traffic
forecasting tool which is a
state-of-the-art tool to predict traffic
based on growth
um
result is we now have a very good
understanding of public commercial and
residential parking needs in the
districts
and a sound strategy for looking forward
to the future
the list of potential schemes has
resulted schemes and proposals and the
next steps will be to assess these and
excessive our variability and their
deliverability some of the schemes are
straightforward and can be done soon
others are more expensive and long term
almost all will be involved the
participation of others in particular
Suffolk highways but this meeting isn't
about the future it's not about how
we're going to implement the schemes
it's about how we've got to this point
and and how we've got the basis for
going forward
strategy reflects the council's
Strategic priorities I feel very well it
reflects the corporate plan and the
district's views of its future and a lot
of hard and thoughtful work has gone
into it and I would really like to take
this opportunity to thank the officers
involved and particularly Sharon Bayless
who isn't Terence and Sarah Gilson who
has been to all the meetings and and
listened to all the things that we've
heard which have been of great interest
and they are to be commended for their
dedication I look forward to taking this
forward and to your comments thank you
thank you councilor Ferry
the officers want to add anything to
um no no thank you I think I think right
members any questions for the officers
or Council affirming
uh with regard to item 4.8 on page 12.
uh
is it correct to assume that we're
talking about car park usage rather than
the growth in the number of car parks
um thank you chair
um yes you're correct that would be
um the the usage of our car parks
Council flaming
um I did just to make that
um a bit clear
um yes it is the usage but
I wouldn't rule out the fact that you
know we may need to add car parks that
isn't ruled out in the strategy
because that may be the case
sorry just to clarify so you're saying
that the strategy could include
additional provision of car parking
Council agency
um 4.2 on page 12. how were those um
that I mean to have a a good strategy
you need good goals because that's the
whole point the strategy is to get to a
goal so before you draw up a strategy we
need to know what the goal is 4.2 seems
to be the goals how are those arrived at
could I refer
red thank you chair
um so
we we
um we sat down with our Consultants we
spoke with our portfolio holders and we
had looked at exactly what our final
destination should look like and what
our Ambitions were linking in with our
joint area management plan and our
parking study report they were the
foundations for moving forward with our
parking strategy and we were Keen to
make sure that we Linked In with our
council's climate emergency declaration
as stated within 1.1 of our report
can I just try and summarize what you
said so you it was in conjunction with
because I'm not sure I heard all of it
it was in conjunction with a portfolio
holder you discussed with the portfolio
holder and took into account various
factors including the
The Joint area management plan is that
right and the and
the climate goals
and was there anything else
you say yes sorry um so it was the joint
management parking plan which was
created in December 2019.
[Music]
and also the um the cabinet report of uh
the 4th of February 2000 which was the
car park study report
2014.
okay thanks thanks
[Music]
we I did raise this when you came and
did the presentation in Sudbury but I
was rather concerned that the um the the
main survey was done in August 21
um when the impact of covid was still
quite relevant
um so I don't think it was an absolutely
true picture and we did raise that at
the time because
particularly in my area was very
restricted with traffic thank you
thank you I think
we have we're very aware of covid and
a lot of I mean work has to go on during
the pandemic we can't
wait until the pandemic's over and
things have got to normal before we
start the strategy you know where we'd
be several years behind so I think we
all know that covid and the pandemic has
hugely affected the way people drive and
car and park and everything but that has
been taken into account in developing
this strategy so we're moving ahead with
this
um I hope that sort of satisfies you
um there really isn't anything else to
do besides not prepare the strategy
that's the alternative
that's right
[Music]
was that I feel because it was the
school holidays as well
and so therefore it was not a true
picture and yes we have to go on with
the strategy but I do feel that maybe
um you should take more more facts and
figures into consideration because it
was yes I understand about covid however
it was about the worst possible time to
do a survey as you did thank you
and if I could just add to that
obviously
um this is a wider program than just one
location so we have had to ensure that
the program is delivered in a timely way
and what I would add is those specific
pieces of work which will form the next
stage which is the recommendations in
the in the action plan that will be
created
um you know if they are significant
projects they will of course be based on
further Evidence so there will be
further opportunities to engage with
communities
perhaps if I could just interject there
perhaps one option might have been to to
mention somewhere in this report that
allowances have been made for the fact
that it was during a period of uh
unusual
circumstances regarding the covid and
the some adjustments may have to be made
to certain aspects of it
over here sorry
um yeah thank you we're sort of we're
sort of touching on it like
um so 2000 responses for the online
survey is very impressive
um how do we um manage to get the um
that amount and um what did we do to
make sure
the um we promoted in it promoted it in
a way that we got the diversity and
quality that we need in that kind of um
survey to get the results that are as
useful as they can possibly be
um
thank you for your question
um so when 2000 surveys completed was
for the stage two of our parking
strategy in total we had over 3 000 when
we take into consideration our um first
stage
um which ran for seven weeks and our
second stage which again ran for seven
weeks we made sure that we promoted
through the use of social media
um
residents were able residents and
members of the public businesses
local Leisure groups were able to come
to Virtual workshops in-person workshops
and briefing sessions in which we were
able to explain our journey to date
and also ask if they were able to
complete online surveys by using a QR
code so they could access that through
mobile device those that were unable to
we had paper copies in which
um people were able to complete and
forward onto us we also spoke and
um at our road shows we had interesting
conversations that were documented with
the people that had come to see us and
again we had copies of our surveys there
for those that were able to
complete them we liaise with town and
Parish councils and local businesses to
make sure that they had a copy of the QR
code and a copy of the surveys in case
people weren't able to come and meet us
at the road shows and so we hope that we
we reached a um
a vast majority of our population
I refer to
item 4.18
um
which has the phrase through a
comprehensive robust and focused
implementation plan I think it's
repeated several times throughout the
document so I have the following
questions
who will prepare the plan and what
process will be used for that
when will it be available and what will
be the time scale for its implementation
um if I made the implementation plan
um
is going to begin
once this strategy is approved
by cabinet and
how long it will take I would say it
will be an ongoing procedure because
some of the steps as I said will be
fairly short term and relatively easy to
bring about but some of them will not
some of them are quite expensive and
will require external funding and some
of them some of the aspirations may not
be deliverable in the short and medium
term at all these are all we're
embarking in a way on
on on a on a New Journey in terms of
providing parking
um for the future
and all that entails so that there's no
definite answers when it will end
um perhaps one of the officers would
like to
um fill in a bit more
um yes I mean the implementation plan I
don't actually think will take too long
um it's not in our interest to spend a
year trying to pull together an
implementation plan so I'd say a match
of months
um to pull that together
um in terms of who
will be uh pulling pulling that plan
together and 419 in in the report talks
about our dedicated officer team
um that or delivery group that group
will be pulled from officers across
across the council to make sure that we
pick up the various different services
that might be impacted by some of the
recommendations But ultimately the the
plan will be based upon the
recommendations which are in the
strategy and so it'll be those
recommendations worked up into more
detail
I've got a question regarding the real
for backing up of real-world data
according to
um in comparison to survey information
I am sure there are those who
any surveys I'm not sure how many people
would actually go around and say that I
am one of those people with pavement
Park
um I I am part of the problem because
human nature is not to we always even
Anonymous we want to see ourselves in
our best night
also when we have going to town councils
and things like that
say if it is a planning
application coming they may want to lean
on what's worse how they see
so we it's human nature to even make
ourselves look better or to focus on the
negative
what real world basis have we got and
again it's been made this has done again
during a period of a very let's say
Global under well
it was a very unusual period
how
does it reflect on how parking was
beforehand because people's memories are
fickle and do adapt and how
are we going to how is it looking to a
future how are we looking to what the
council opinion is going to be for what
we need or what people's opinions what
can it be needed for the future
can I just I'll just start off thank you
very much um for your question
um
I think I just
want to draw attention to the fact that
the um the whereas the online surveys
were done in in
2021 the road shows and the meetings
with local communities and parishes were
done mostly this summer
and I think we were pretty well over the
pandemic then
as far as I recall we are more or less
back to normal from the beginning of
this year so I think that whereas
there's an element of pandemic influence
at the beginning initially
the strategy largely reflects a return
to more normal circumstances that we're
seeing now so um
from that aspect you know I feel
confident that that we're in good hands
and moving forward into implementation
we will be going back again to um to
consult on specific plans so there will
be an opportunity to to bring the
information that supports this strategy
you know up to the current situation and
reflect it I see the implementation plan
as actually being a living document
and I think that's a really important to
consider this will be very interactive
with both councilors members and the
public and the towns and parishes
involved so I I think
um
without being rigid it can adapt to you
know the the issue that you've raised
give you some reassurance
it does give me some reassurance it
does offer for services a living
document
has this not already gone to cabinets
and have we not already published it
part of it in a part of this
going out to public because I believe
I've seen something in the cabinet
that's already looked at
and I wasn't aware that this is the
living document isn't has it been made
clear so I'm very confused
this is not a living document the
implementation plan will be
this the strategy will be reviewed
periodically during its 40-year life
um every three to five years or shorter
if needed but as it stands it's not a
living document
when it's approved it will be a set
document
as well
thank you chair a couple of questions
um
how does the strategy inform the
planning process I'm thinking in
particular of we're still approving
housing Estates with inadequate parking
in terms of parking on the actual
dwelling premises and that means that
you get on street parking
um so particularly in in Stone Market we
have some states that are 10 15 years
old where the parking is as bad on the
road as it is in Victorian quarter of
the town which was never of course
designed for cars so how does the
strategy inform the planning process
that would be question one
um
and I'm really interested in how this
moves forward we're talking about a
detailed business case for major cost
implications we're talking about the
implementation plan how do you how do
you foresee this moving forward do all
of those go to the cabinet or do they
come to scrutiny for pre-scrutinizing
before it goes to Cabinet how do you see
the process moving forward on the
implementation plan
thank you thank you very much councilor
scarf and you raised the point of how
this will be used in terms of planning
and that's that is a really good point
and we've just we've discussed that
actually and um I think planning
um
decisions will need to take account of
the existence of the parking strategy
particularly when it comes to the design
of new developments pre-application
advice and
um
suppose the decisions of the planning
committee members as well it's there to
help steer really better parking
provision in new developments than we've
received before particularly residential
parking
um you know I've sat on a planning
committee I know exactly what you're
talking about and I think one of the key
functions of the parking strategy will
be to improve that process and to work
with planners I think we have we have
plans to discuss the document and our
expectations directly with planners and
that's going to be happening once it's
approved
Fiona
just to add to that is probably likely
to work in a similar way to the LC whip
that's now approved which
um we're finding is really a very a very
useful document in having those very
early conversations with planners when
they get pre-application
um pre-applications in and so we see it
working in a very similar way and and
what the LC whip has enabled us to do is
have a much closer working relationship
with planning officers because it's
something that we can actually discuss
with them around applications so that's
where we see it being very very useful
thank you I just might would add that
both the Elsie Whip and the parking
strategy um
we've already discussed the LC whip with
Suffolk highways and we will be doing
the same with the parking strategy it
gives us an extra tool to work
proactively with them because sometimes
their advice
on
parking and highways issues is fairly
minimal I think we all know that so I
think this a key function of this is to
improve that process
going on to moving forward and um
see how this will be can you just repeat
exactly what
you well it was it was really about
um
the major costs would have to be covered
by a detailed business case because you
have to justify what you're spending I
can see that
um what process it's the governance
process where does it go from here does
it go to Cabinet first and then can be
scrutinized or called in does it go to
scrutiny first a detailed business case
the implementation plan I'm really
interested in how we actually move
forward on the documents
um I I think I'd probably refer to
officers but I think every detail of the
implementation plan
um specifically would probably not go
through scrutiny and cabinet because
otherwise it would take it would be like
you're trying to hit a moving Target
there'd be too many relatively minor
projects coming forward but um probably
as a whole and in principle I would
imagine that the document might go
through scrutiny and cabinet but that
I'm not sure possibly as for information
and noting rather than approval but here
again I'm guessing so I'll hand over
thank you
um yes I think I think um Council
Fleming said what I was going to say
really which is uh it really depends on
the nature of of each of the elements
you know the larger ones that require a
business case I would absolutely expect
a formal process to be agreed for them I
can't tell you what that is right now
because I don't know what or they are in
detail but but for some of the smaller
areas which might just be about tweaking
tweaking signage or the website I don't
imagine that you'd necessarily want to
be bothered by some of that information
so it'll be very much targeted upon you
know the high the higher level the more
costly and the more impactful items in
that implementation plan
and could I just add that um I'm sure
that the council will keep everyone
including ons committee informed about
how the plan develops and in a way it's
up to you to say whether you believe
a project is significant enough to come
to your formal attention or whether you
you can just sort of bless it in its
current
like
one of the things for instance we'd like
to extend one hour parking in Needham
Market to two hours because no one has a
chance to have their hair done in a
coffee in one hour and simple things
like that you probably don't want to
come before you but big there are some
really big items here which involve
major expenses and those you might want
to consider so in a way it's up to you
rather than us
cancel 11.
thank you chair
um Council Fleming referred to us being
back to normal circumstances I wonder if
we are back to normal circumstances so
that brings me to this question is the
process to come up with a strategy now
complete I assume it is all you believe
it is
so how can the strategy be further
developed as we move to a new normal I
don't think the new normal is going to
be the normal that was normal back in
2020 for a number of reasons we've got
the cost of fuel that's gone up so
presumably the strategy will need to
take account of fewer Journeys because
of the if there are fewer Journeys
because of the cost of fuel we've also
got the cost of living crisis we've got
fewer people commuting by train so
there's a lot of things that have
changed
um and then yeah in mid-suffolk we've
got the electric bus project which I
think many of the councilors hope will
result in fewer car Journeys into places
like stowmarket to park or into eye to
Park or wherever
um
so
can the can the strategy or the
I'm trying not to refer to the stretch
we're trying to refer only to the
process but will the process be be
ongoing or will there be sort of
iterative processes to take account of
these things
um
I'm assuming that the strategy is going
to be set in concrete but the the
implementation plans will change with
time but I'm wondering if the strategy
as it's been developed in this by this
process is going to be able to be set in
concrete I wonder if the strategy is
going to to need to be looked at I'd
like to ask about what input there was
from Suffolk County Council into the
process
um and you know are they not only in the
process but are they involved in the
development of the have they been
involved in the development of the
strategy and are are they going to be
involved I think you said they would be
involved in the implementation of the
strategy because they have to
um and I was interested in
um in the question that councilor scarf
asked and and the response
do you do you think that the strategy
will be able to overrule can we will
planning committees be able to use the
strategy to overrule the County Council
parking standards
I've been I've been on I've been to two
planning committees in the last 48 hours
and
parking standards have been one of the
most difficult things to get sorted
um and it's because the developer says
that the residents are saying and the
district councilors to say it won't work
and the developers say ah but it's at
the County council's Parking standards
we can have triple parking we can do
this we can do that
but will the strategy be able to be
taken into account and to overrule the
views of the highway Authority
okay
I think there are
two probably three questions in there
let me take um
first note let me take the last one
first
um Can the
parking strategy overrule the county
council's parking standards no it can't
but it can certainly be used
to um
mitigate or to to adapt
those I mean the parking
strategy
obviously once it's
completed
um
it will be consulted with I mean
highways has really not been directly
consulted
has it
um
because the the key role for highways is
in the implementation we haven't really
heard from highways
yeah you could go in
um so thank you for your questions just
to touch on um input from Suffolk County
Council we've had regular briefing
sessions with their growth and transport
departments so they're aware of our
um our journey to date they've also um
this week had the links sent to them for
our parking strategy work that we've had
and whilst they will be required to
assist for on-street development the off
street parking remains with ourselves so
it will be on Street matters that
they'll be Keen to be involved in and as
I say they've attended briefing sessions
with us and also they're working on
their local transport plan the draft for
that at the moment in which they'll be
able to refer to our parking strategy
um if this is adopted at cabinet
what's up so hopefully that answers that
question
um
but the parking the month that the
highways has actually influenced the
strategy is I think minimal at this
stage it's a matter of how we work with
them on it Taking It Forward that's the
key thing
um
in terms of
whether or not the strategy can reflect
um
you know it is set in stone and
therefore it reflects a
um a past situation that isn't the
present I think is that's what you're
saying that because it was prepared over
a period of um
some upheaval that it it doesn't reflect
the future going forward well I think
we've sort of discussed that earlier
um
and also it will
available to be reviewed and updated
um as as required really but as we
believe every three to five years should
be sufficient and I feel that in three
years time we'll have a much better idea
of what
you know if it needs to be reviewed and
updated how that should be we couldn't
possibly know that now because I think
as you've pointed out we still haven't
normalized whatever normal is I mean
maybe there is no such thing as normal
really because life changes constantly
so you're dealing with constant change
and dealing with change is difficult
when you're trying to have things that
are set in stone because those two need
to change but they can't be changing all
the time so it's it's marrying that
situation that I think is the roof of
your question and I think this strategy
does that to the best you know possible
ability that that any document could
um
let's see moving does that sort of
respond to your concern
um that's responded to most of it nearly
all of it
um my other concern was around you you
said that the specialist consultant had
access to some algorithm or some
um some method of some prediction method
now if that prediction method included
things like the cost of fuel and and so
on
that will have been out of date by now
I just wonder if if it
if if that that that sort of process
needs to be looked at again
that prediction because that was
predicting that was being used to
predict when car Parks will be 85 full I
think
but already
we know that the price of fuel has gone
up
and
um uh commuting has gone down so it may
well be that if if that
prediction process has been updated
if it could be used now I can't be used
between now and Monday I know but if
that if that was if that was used again
now with the current
taking a cap current prices and current
um parking and commuting whether it
would come up with a different answer
which is being fed into this into the
strategy
that that I I can't say but I think
we've used the most current
um you know government
model that's available by a reputable
National consultant I don't see how we
can really do better than that and my
guess is that if this is looked at say
in three years time the same model would
be employed and it may be different at
the moment we're dealing with a high
level answer of uncertainty in terms of
costs and behavior and I wouldn't want
to predict what the situation would be
like in two years I I doubt if a model
can do it accurately at this point
to the degree that you're
clearly expecting a model to do
you know we have to deal with
uncertainty and move on I suppose is my
response
oh
thank you chairman uh just following on
from counselors question I think it's
um important to note that any kind of
model such as the models that we've been
using with regard to the parking
strategy do evolve and change over time
so if we're going to as we rightly
should do have periodic reviews of the
strategy then I think that at that point
in time that might that would come into
play I think it would also come into
play during the implementation phase of
um so in regard to that I'm not entirely
clear about the planning process with
regard to the strategy of parking
because as councilor Fleming has alluded
to this is a spanning a 20-year period
and we have uh particularly in our urban
areas short term
parking issues that need to be addressed
as and then you know obviously
medium and long-term ones and I'm very
keen to understand what is the process
that we're going to adopt in the
planning is it one overarching plan or
is it a set of subsidiary plans because
I think our residents are going to want
to know after this whole consultations
that we've been through is what are we
going to do in the short term to
ameliorate some of the really dire
parking issues they're facing
right I think I'll let um one of the
officers respond to that thank you
so I think we straying a little bit into
the implementation plan that isn't
written yet
um in terms of the strategy itself I
think it's already been mentioned that
the strategy will need to be regularly
reviewed to ensure that the information
and the direction of travel because
that's what the strategy is really
providing is is appropriate
um clearly when we come to look at
individual implementation whether that
involves discussions with planners
around specific schemes Etc
um we need we do need to make sure that
the evidence base that sits with that is
is up to date so if there is a need to
look at specific areas of evidence then
we will have to you know we'll have to
do that for that business case for that
particular item
is that kind of answer the question
actually not entirely
I'm sorry to say
um I think partly it does I mean I can
understand
that you know where there there are
significant cost implications there are
going to you're going to need to create
an Evidence base to substantiate it
for me that doesn't address the some of
the short-term parking problems which I
don't believe would require a
substantive business case I think if you
could come back to that yeah sorry I
misunderstood
um
obviously in in the implementation plan
sorry I keep referring to that the
implementation plan that isn't yet
written but
um there will be a mix or there will
need to be a mix of shorter term
priorities and slightly longer term
priorities
um where there are shorter term
priorities than um
as with any other action that we need to
take we need to make sure we engage with
all the relevant parties and get the
relevant information behind that but we
would absolutely anticipate that
um you know where we can use this
strategy to influence shorter short
medium and long-term priorities then we
will do because not all of these actions
are hopefully going to take 10 or 20
years so yes to answer your question we
want to use this strategy in the best
way possible to inform current
conversations to bring about action soon
thanks chair I'm afraid I've I've got
quite a few questions but I'll try and
ask them all at once
um and try and make them as easy as
possible to remember and simple as
possible but it's really about the
evidence base
that you collected to come up with this
strategy so it is about the process and
particularly about those
those little arrows that you've got that
feed into the off street parking theme
and the on-street parking theme
and where I I can't the sort of gaps I
think in in the the evidence space we
need but perhaps you can correct me on
that
um was so the first one is
[Music]
um
we know that all the surveys show
between 40 and 50 of Journeys in our
towns are less than one and a half miles
um which implies that
we can we have a tool with a parking
strategy to change Behavior to if if we
um one way or the other we can encourage
more cars onto the road and more parking
by providing more parking places
or we can um
so it's called induced demand
we can actually induce extra demand for
car parking by providing more car
parking spaces
if we if you've got a car park where
half the people in that car park have
only driven one and a half miles
that tells you even if it's 85 90 100
full if half of them have only driven
one and a half miles
then surely we should be reducing the
car parking space not increasing
provision which the recommendations
I currently say we should increase
provision if the car park is more than
85 full so my question there is
what account have we taken in the
evidence of
the impact of induced demand a
increasing provision of car parking on
the actual demand for car parking
because I see one of the goals is to
reduce demand for parking and I but I
don't see much in the recommendations to
actually it will actually get us there
and the other question is more
specifically
the distance any of did we do any
surveys of people the people actually
parking in car Parks the distance they
traveled and the purpose of their
Journey
um because what we shouldn't be
providing car parking uh really I don't
believe for people who want to drive one
and a half miles or less
um that's the second question the third
question
um was any attack count taken of the
number of people in baber and
mid-suffolk who don't have access to a
car I see the one of the goals
is um
well in the paper it states
um
[Applause]
just get there
ensure earn in 4.2 ensures everyone has
access to sufficient good quality safe
and welcoming parking opportunities
well there's probably five to ten
percent of people in our districts who
don't have a car at all
um so are we saying we're going to buy
them a car so they've got a parking
opportunity
um
uh the the Gold's a bit better I prefer
the wording of the goal in the actual um
the actual recommendations
um but still
um
I think we need to take better account
the fact that a large proportion a
significant proportion of population
[Music]
does not have access to a car and what
is the impact of
increasing or changing car parking
provision on them
because they may feel that there are too
many cars parked on their route to to
the shops or whatever and they're
actually a hindrance
um so that's question three
um
the evidence
for the impact of parking on businesses
um now it's it's all very well to survey
businesses and business owners and I bet
you ninety percent of them say I'm
depending my business on the High Street
is dependent on the people who come and
park right outside my shop and I I go
bust if if you took that parking space
away I'm going to go bust
all the the case studies
um that are being produced
um
show that actually that's that's what
the shopkeepers think but when you
remove parking some parking reduce
parking on the High Street
there's The Pedestrian pound effect and
actually people who walk there or cycled
there or come by bus tend to spend more
up ahead than the person who's just
popped in with the car parked there
popped out and and gone off again
so it actually increases income for
businesses if you reduce parking
Provisions so has any has has there been
any
um evidence taken from other areas where
they've where they've actually
successfully reduced parking provision
um and there are a wealth of surveys
particularly by people like living
streets
um but because that's not been mentioned
in this as as um the evidential basis uh
so that's question four we're nearly
there uh two more
um the we've mentioned the the the the
bit the algorithm or whatever it is the
software that you've used to predict
future parking tempro
um does that
uh adapt for local dude I mean I'm
interested in what figures you plug in
here because we don't we don't it
doesn't say that
um because
the local demographics here we know is
that the population is aging
um and elderly people there's a far
higher proportion who either can't or
don't drive
and maybe don't have access to a car
um so if we use but if we're using some
if we're not taking account of that then
we'll get a wrong figure for for the
increase
uh if there is an increase in in demand
for parking
[Music]
um
and
yeah I think
that that I I just I I suppose the look
the last question is just to take it all
in how do you reconcile
the goals of
ensuring everyone has access to
sufficient good quality self and
welcoming parking opportunities
with
um
the goal of reducing the impact of our
activities on the environment
because to me they seem to be
contradictory goals thanks
[Music]
okay thank you thank you very much
[Music]
um
I'll attempt to answer these in order I
may need some assistance from from
officers
um
the first question
you Center on the fact that
um 40 to 50 percent of people apparently
our district car Parks have traveled
less than one and a half miles
[Music]
um
but they're still parking their car
they're still well
the strategy is also about cycle parking
it's not just about car parking
so cyclists will have responded as well
and they need to have somewhere to park
their bikes they can't all just lean
them up against shops
so our strategy does take into account
people who don't use the car
and um
you know we have to trust that people
who use their cars need to use them I
think we all know that the weather in
Britain during the winter
you know isn't conducive for everyone to
to walk or cycle one and a half miles
um especially if you're elderly and I
think we need to as you said a large
relatively large proportion of people in
the districts are relatively elderly but
still driving
and
for the most part
quite honestly they're not going to
cycle in the winter that's a good half
of the year
and that's the reality and we need to
account for them and not discriminate
against them because they're not cycling
just because they don't
you know feel like it we're doing what
we
can to increase cycling in fact we had a
meeting at itown Council on the LC whip
um
it was the night before last and we had
a representation of the County Council
cycling officer and looking at all kinds
of ways to make cycling just
more acceptable to more people to make
people less afraid of cycling to offer
workshops so that they could learn how
to fix their bicycles all that kind of
thing and looking for volunteers to lead
people on cycling routes so I mean we're
doing all we can but you're going to
come up against a set of people who just
simply will not or cannot
cycle or walk and those are the people
with this strategy needs to
accommodate
um
you mentioned people who do not have
access to a car that they may be somehow
resentful of cars and are approached
providing parking for people who need to
use their car to do local business
um I don't think there are very many of
those people around and you know I don't
think that's a survey that I've ever
heard of I don't think we have
information about how many people feel
that way
um
impacts on people who do not yeah too
many cars well I agree I think there are
too many cars but there's not a lot we
can do about it it's it's how people are
living now and as people move into
electric cars and maybe as older people
use AI
um
we'll still have cars people will still
need to get around and we'll need to
accommodate them
um business parking
um hmm
we talk to a lot of businesses we had
meetings with stowmarket Needham Market
I debenham I'm talking about mid-suffolk
and I'm sure in baber the same meetings
took place and I think we all know that
high streets are struggling to get
people into their shops and we need to
be encouraging people to come in and do
their business and
um a repeated theme that that I heard
was that parking needs to be user
friendly and that's why things like
giving people adequate time when they do
come in and park on the High Street to
do their business is so important
encouraging
um quite honestly the economic viability
of our small towns which we have a lot
of in mid-suffolk and Bay but we don't
have a lot of large towns in cities we
don't have an Ipswich or a Burris and
Edmonds so it's a different situation
we're dealing with a rural area and
if our turns lose any more of their
shops and centers people
you won't have a parking problem because
people will be heading off to the big
towns to the Tescos and asdas and things
they won't be doing the sort of things
we want to encourage which is using our
small shops and encouraging the small
businesses that that are of the moment
struggling greatly so I think we need to
be listening to our businesses and
trying to help them survive so what's
been a really difficult period
um in terms of the does temper the model
take into account
um an aging population I I don't know
the answer of that question I'm not
familiar enough with the model but I do
know that when the model is reapplied at
a future date
that it will take into account
both local and National current data
whatever that is and um
I think that will resolve any issues
with its inaccuracy no model is
perfectly accurate
um
I think that's about it for the list of
questions that I had jotted down
thank you you covered them all and I
appreciate you doing that apart from the
last one which was reconciling
providing parking for all with reducing
the environmental impact
right well I I mean I think we all know
that there's a conflict between what
man does and what nature might want and
you know Cars For Better or Worse are
with us personally I'd much rather be
going around by horse or bicycle but
that's just not possible
um we have to drive a car to get around
and dealing with that friction is
something that you know we all do to the
best of our ability but not to provide
adequate car parking would be a
dereliction of this council's Duty and
that's what this strategy is attempting
to do
in this you know to the best of its
ability
um you the question five I think you
you said you could can the officers help
a bit with a bit more detail about
whether um
that that was question five was ten bro
yeah
I think based on predictions of future
housing population car ownership trip
rates and jobs and it is relevant to the
local areas not just a national
statistic
nice
yeah it takes into account population
demographic yes
population demographic yes which will
include the Aging population
thank you very much um when we were
collecting data
um in this um exercise
how much um
weight did we put on um existing
problems and issues I can I can see a
lot about modeling was that um
existing issues
um side of things useful did we collect
the data and um did we have any way of
um dealing with data that was outside of
what we were um wanting to collect but
was still useful for what we were trying
to achieve
thank you for your question
um so collating the data was this is a
high level strategic um
the level of data um could you just
could you just confirm the data that
you're referring to if it's a car
parking data on Street data so what I'm
what I'm picturing is um potentially a
heat map of problems in parking where
enforcement
um notifications have had to be used and
also the public have had issues because
I'm I'm sure you didn't go through this
without hearing about a lot of issues in
different places
um we we um so when it comes to the
enforcement we've worked and collated
data from our partners at Ipswich
Borough Council and also West Suffolk
Council who um are responsible for
issuing penalty charge notices within
our car parks and also on street so
we're able to pull data
um where penalty charge notices had been
issued and hotspot areas we also
collated data on um car park usage so
our payment machines are able to tell us
how many tickets have been issued within
within the car parks and for the lengths
of stay
um so so that all falls into our study
report so which is on our on our website
um and uh
contains more more of the detail that
you may be looking for
and sodium then the um and the public as
well the Public's issues
indeed so when we
when we're late
um 235 Pages worth of feedback where we
had free text boxes within our online
surveys where um whoever was completing
the survey were able to give us some
more of the detail about where they may
be
um
finding problems in their local area
because whilst it's great to understand
how people feel about our
recommendations we did need to
understand where their concerns may have
been so we have that information again
listed um and it's not been tampered
with it's as people had completed that
information is shared within our website
and will also be one of the appendix
going through two cabinets
thank you members I think we've given
the office as a fair grilling now this
is something different is it
as we're going round and round in
circles a little bit I think and we want
to move on to debate if we can but
what's your question
yes it's just a very quick question uh
regarding well
some of the answers have are open to
more questions regarding
um
we're looking at Provisions for shops
but if there's no adequate Park in the
area near the local shops
if we are looking at providing parking
elsewhere again it's not opening what um
councilor Lindsay's thing perhaps
opening demands and having the space of
Park cars is not going to encourage it
and not actually solve a problem of
people who can't get to buy local shops
is this also looking at problems where
we have existed where car park is in
place but the walk around for
pedestrians is currently inadequate so
actually
um uh how I just looked at the same
revision
and also last the last question is um we
are doing this we can introduction with
a the environment as well is this being
looked into combined with other schemes
such as the anti-idling one I've heard
comments about the the changing of
um road signs is this going to be looked
at where we have got problems people
parking the cars they have provisional
cars but are idling and therefore
impacts in the environment can we as
part of this scheme look at tackling for
outside of parkings also
um and this game isn't really intended
to address
idling except
clearly the easier it is to find a
parking space the less idling there will
be
um
I'm not quite sure exactly what your
other question is if you could make it
very succinct
if they're on regarding you said about
to look it out for your shops and no
placement
if there's a shop located in an area
that hasn't got a parking provision
cannot have parking provision how will
providing more parking elsewhere Aid
that job
all these questions about regarding the
access of pedestrians where we have
parking provided but we have not
provided by lighting or things to
prevent and parking pass the Line This
is not currently looked at being
provided any barrier to prevent it how
are we going to ensure that we are
providing parking but not taking away
pedestrian access at the same time
I I think you're talking about potential
new pub are you new car parks
or is it um pedestrian access from
existing car parks
okay well existing car Parks I think
you know they're they're
because
you know that historically there's been
a car park there and people are
accustomed to using them and walking to
and from them
I think if there were any new car Parks
established obviously pedestrian access
to you know the desired destination
would be a very important part of where
they're located and and how they're
planned
the axis was talking about where those
parking and the people with the cars
park against adjacent to walls where
there's there's marking for pedestrians
to walk but we have no prevention of
cars parking where predictions are and
are we looking at ensuring that where
people Park are not impacting the
already but we have impacts on
I think that will be part of the
rotation plan but can I hand over if
anyone has another comment
of course I think you're talking about
Verge pavement parking and green space
areas where people are parking on verges
at the moment would that be correct
um
no I was actually talking about the
examples being
Regal outside or uh
the
train station need a market or the
Leisure Center mid-suffolk Leisure
Center where we have no bollarding
preventing for cars to be parked against
beside Road and we park on where there's
lines for pedestrian access
for people to access but there's no way
of doing it
I understand so that will link through
in our implementation plan where we're
looking at the fine detail in certain
locations and also we'll be looking at
our user groups as to why people are
parking where they're parking
in regards to car parks and the shop
areas so it's going to be the
implementation plan we'll be going into
more detail the strategy will be the uh
the reference document that will set the
high level and and the the guidance that
we'll be following and then the
implementation plan will look at that
detail
I think no further questions we've now
opened it up for debate and just bear in
mind that on page 11 of your papers
there are three recommendations
um not saying that we have to accept
those three recommendations but let's
have the debate
aiming to produce some sort of
conclusion to uh for this extensive
discussion that's already been held
around the questions
anybody
cancel casting
thank you very much yeah I I think this
is the um personally think this is a
really good piece of work it's um I
think it's it seems to be very thorough
and it's going to be um
very useful because Parkins obviously
something that we really need to stay
ahead of
um going forward and
these um well there's been a little bit
of talk about the sort of
unknowns going forward and the known
unknowns
um and um I think all this modeling and
everything prepares us really well for
that
um it's um you know this will eventually
be a living document that can be adapted
will will have the base there to adapt
it very quickly and and deal with what
the future brings
um
I do um
the only thing that I think is missing
from this is
um looking at um the car sharing that
goes on
um and Van sharing where um on the A14
Corridor and the hubs where um people um
go to work and they jump and they need
somewhere to park
and they jump in a car and go onto a you
know they're onward um journey and they
um it's sharing a car
um I think this happens quite a lot in
um mid-suffolk and and I'm sure in favor
um very similar we
I think to alleviate some of these
parking issues that we have especially
with
um the roadside parking we do need to
look at that and how how that affects
um the um you know long-term people
parking for eight ten hours in a day in
different areas different hubs affects
how this all works in this model the um
and I think the biggest thing about it I
think people should be able to do it
very easily they shouldn't feel bad if
you're if you're car sharing and you get
into someone else's car too and say that
it's a one one vehicle goes into Ipswich
from Stow Market I don't think that you
should be put in a position where you
have to find a parking space that you
think might upset a um a resident or you
you might find a ticket on your card or
anything like that
um so provision for that
I think would make a big difference
um
there's I I don't know whether that's
necessarily what this is about but I
think that's probably
systemically that's part of the parking
issue but um no apart from that side of
things I yeah fantastic bit of work it's
great to see consultation done like this
so thoroughly and um you know to reach
out to so many people like the
to get um almost 3 000 people or over 3
000 people sorry um to answer an online
questionnaire is some I think you should
be a recommendous you've done very well
with that
um so um yeah I am
I'll um
I'll pass over to um other members I
won't I won't talk on the conditions but
um
I'm sure other members I think some of
the points that you're making there are
veering into the next stage after this I
look at this a bit like a pyramid
or an iceberg we're looking at the
little bit that's sticking up above the
water the bit to come it's a bit that's
below the water and that is the bit
that's going to address the uh the
problem of on-street parking across our
whole District both districts and
the Implement yeah I know but I think it
is
yeah yeah we need to um not not
belittling what's what's going on to God
on so far
important because without that data you
can't actually start to produce any sort
of meaningful plan to address it that's
a scarf
picture
um well I mean I I certainly welcome the
parking strategy because we've never had
one before and I've always wondered
being a member uh in in Stone Market
which has of course considerable number
of mid-suffix car Parks why we've never
had one before
and this will help to I think identify
the investment required in those car
parks and the flexibility required in
those car parks to make sure
that those car Parks serve the needs of
people serve the needs of the local
economy business retailers Etc so I
think um very much welcome the strategy
I think for me with the recommendations
3.3 is the most important one to me
how we as a overburned scrutiny
committee get further
chances to look at the situation I I
would really like once the
implementation plan is developed whether
it's two three months or I'm presuming a
fairly short time based on what the
officers have said I would really like
us as a joint committee to have a chance
to look at the implementation Plan
before it goes to a pre-scrutiny before
it goes to cabinet because it'll have to
go to Cabinet anyway
and I would like to see us have a
regular updates even if they're only
information bulletins on where we're at
and that could be a process of small
scale changes like the hourly limits in
the car park or the flexibility by
making a car park one side up to three
hours on the other side long-term
parking
small little things that can be done I'd
like to see those small little things
actually documented and I'd also like to
see how we're going to implement some of
the larger scale things like the signage
perhaps electronic signage in Stone
Market which is potentially part of the
plan so that we can actually direct
people to the right car parks and
actually reduce the amount of traffic
flowing around town constantly looking
for a car park because some of the car
parks are already at over capacity so
for me I think the overview and scrutiny
committees role should be a regular one
looking at this and making sure that
we're actually doing something with all
this money that we've actually spent on
the strategy development and it's
actually you know being delivered
yeah I'm afraid that um
I I don't I don't think
the you know have seen the strategy
we've got and and
um that comes from
the evidence that the process
and uh that we're looking at
and
um
I I don't think it it meets the job of
meeting the girl one of the goals was
to reduce the environmental impact
I'm very concerned that the
recommendations
seem to have this
have set this 85 if a car park is more
than 85 percent full then we need to we
as a council need to start looking for
land to provide a new car park provide
extra virgin
and from the answers that
[Music]
I got from the cabinet member it seems
like there's been no I I specifically
asked have we looked at any case studies
where where
councils have reduced parking seen what
impact that has on business whether it
works where the people change their
behavior and I didn't get an answer but
I assumed I assume it the answer is no
um I was just told there's not a lot we
can do about it well you know the fact
is if people are only driving a short
distance and they you know we all know
we all do it you know drive a mile
um when we perfectly fit and healthy if
there's no car park if they can't get a
parking space people change their
behavior and people will decide to walk
instead
or cycle or get the bus
um and if if the car parts full it's a
signal to us
find to invest not in extra car park
provision but alternative ways to travel
to invest in space for pedestrians make
it safer for people to walk and cycle
into towns like Sudbury
and and Stow Market
um
so I don't I don't think the
um
I think we you know what we've done is
um and it's you know I really appreciate
all the work and I I hate to sort of say
I think it's all been wasted I don't
think it all has it's important to to
get people's views
um and that seems to be done very
thoroughly but I think it's even more
important if one of our goals is to
reduce car parking demand
is to look up areas where they've done
that successfully and see what we can
copy from that
and I don't see I haven't been told I've
asked the question I haven't been told
that we've done that at all and I think
we need to you know I think we need to
say to cabinet
first get some evidence first look at
what what other councils have done
before we launch into this strategy
which has
already been drawn up which says that
we're automatically provide more car
parking provision if if car parks are 85
full
I just well I want to um Talk on that a
little bit I can absolutely understand
what the council is saying but um I
think if we're gonna have a strategy
that makes car parking worse um could we
please not do it in Stone Market
um the um but no I do completely
understand what
um he's saying but um the fact is we're
looking at very short Journeys which is
great okay the people could walk not
everyone's in a position to walk I'd end
up trying to walk to a shop at 10
o'clock at night if I couldn't Park
um and I'd probably get in the car and
drive past
the place that had um less car parking
to go to somewhere where I could park
easily but um it's um I think this
strategy here is just really important
because we need to look after the um
local economy in our towns and this car
parking is absolutely essential the only
places that are still thriving have got
good car parking facilities
um it's um it's massively important but
um
I yeah I can understand where you're
trying to get to but I just don't I
don't think reducing car parking spaces
would do that I think it'd just means
people carry on
past and go to other places
and see what it does
well I think it's a there's a bit of a
chicken and egg situation there you say
you need the evidence
other people say that they uh it will
provide it will mean that people go
somewhere else I think what we've got to
make sure is that there is a balance
between the provision of car parking
which is I think the main objective of
this document
a balance between the provision of car
parking and alternative means of getting
to where people want to go
because there's no point in denying
people parking facilities for instance
in our villages
if there's no bus service
because they've got to use their car
and so it's a question of balancing all
the various aspects across the various
needs across the whole District
full
Yes actually I do agree with your last
statement
um you know clearly
um
the use we're not going to get rid of
the use of cars particularly in our
rural districts
um unless we were to have really
comprehensive uh public transport
um which were I don't think anywhere
near being able to do
um but I do think that an element and I
do welcome the strategy for car parking
I think it's an important step forward
but I do think that in the wider context
there is a a task
to be addressed which is actually the
judicious use of cars and I think
councilman Lindsay's point is is not to
be ignored about you know the short
distances people will travel in their
cars to just for the convenience because
they have the car and so it's quick and
easy
um particularly when we are faced with
quite severe health issues within our
populations whether they be the older
folk or indeed sadly the younger folk
so to my mind one of the areas that we
really I don't know this strategy will
address it but we need to look at in the
longer term is is the way in which
people transport their children to
school and those are definitely fall in
all the short distance traveling and I
and I think there's a a task there in
terms of as I say getting people to use
their cars judiciously and and and and
not just
it's not their blinking right leg you
know sort of thing if I may use that
sort of terminology so I think in in the
circumstances in which the overview and
scrutiny is looking at the particular
strategy in front of us then you know
the recommendations I think are are us
our Sounders were likely to get and I
think I would agree with councilor scarf
that we really need to pay uh or be have
the opportunity to pay much more
attention to the in planning and
implementation process
um I hear what councilor Fleming had to
say about the impact on planning and I
have to say sadly I disagree with that
entirely I don't think it would have any
influence on the planning process at all
um just just the fact of it I mean
nothing else has had influence on on
planning so I don't see why this should
um but nevertheless I think we should
welcome the strategy and we should we
should press ahead
now especially welcome
um
Council open on a point regarding the
school that was going to be my point and
I had wondered about what evidence had
been collected again which is uh Council
Lindsay's point where there are other
strategies in place regarding this
um one of it for instance being uh
uh permitting parking for only residents
by schools because of one of the major
problems of people parking outside
schools and blocking off Pathways so
it'd be I'm assuming to be
re-inflammation process here but we'll
look at this
uh will this make a reduction I'm not
I'm as uncertain but
yes I completely welcome Castle
Lindsey's point about we need to address
reducing or driving we need to address
these smaller Journeys parking going to
schools we need to address as well
ensuring that pedestrian access is
looked into
um
regards to ensuite parking so these are
the factors that I
yeah but
as for recommendations
I
I especially like um recommendation
3.1 or 1ish
we're going to cabinet where it's
already in the cabinet papers love that
but anyway
thank you
thank you chair
um yeah I really appreciate the amount
of work that the officers have carried
out I mean it's been oh it's been almost
a full-time job collecting data over a
long period of time and we've met on a
number of occasions in various places I
appreciate all of that work there is a
massive data there that's been analyzed
and I appreciate all that work
um yeah if I if I could turn the clock
back I would say what we really need is
an overarching strategy for access to
destinations not a car parking strategy
first
um but we are where we are
um unfortunately this
the the
it's difficult to uh to comment
or debate the process for arriving at
the strategy having read the strategy
um because I can having read the
strategy I can see that there's little
in there
um to ensure safe and convenient access
for all there's there's quite a lot in
there about car parking
but there needs to be there needs to be
more the the districts need to do more
to ensure that there are other methods
of getting to shops to the Leisure
centers and various places but that's
not that's not what your task was your
time you've completed your task
um in my view it's a wrong task
but there we are
um but I would I would like to to see
more in the strategy in due course about
reducing car use
but we need to determine what amount of
car parking is really essential
that needs to be safe and it needs to be
convenient not just convenient for the
car user but for convenient for people
who once they're parked their car to
walk to their destination
whilst not making it difficult for
people who want to walk through the
copper and cut some of the car parks are
situated in locations uh
where residents are walking from
somewhere else to somewhere else through
the car park and it's not safe to do so
um so we need to be very careful about
the lay the layer of our car park that
it doesn't just cater for the car it
caters for people who are walking from A
to B
um as far as the recommendations are
concerned well I I think that um the
chair and I are booked to appear at
cabinet on Monday anyway
um and so I've I've been writing some
notes of what I might I might say
um in respect to 3.3
yeah we need an update but we don't need
too many updates we've got we we were in
the process some years ago of having
updates on particular topics every three
months or on one particular topic every
time we met we we want we want uh only
to have an update report when we need an
update report
um
I don't think we've got time in 3.2 I
don't think we've got time to
particularly produce a written written
recommendations to Cabinet will will
make a verbal presentation but hopefully
we'll both say roughly the same thing
and we'll type it out in advance so they
will end your course be a a a
he'll be able to have a site of the of
the recommendations that we present to
uh to Cabinet
um
so yeah that I think that's that's where
we are we are as far as recommendations
are concerned yeah we we've noted we've
noted the re the report our comments
will go on to to cabinet on the 3rd of
October
um we will provide
verbal recommendations to cabinet
based on what has been said in the in
the debate here
um and uh
we would like
I would propose that we would like a an
update report at some point in the
future which will take account of the
The New Normal circumstances which
we don't know when that when things will
settle down but they certainly haven't
settled down yet
so if that can be that's a proposal it's
a rather waffely proposal but uh so are
those proposals basically the
recommendations on page 11. to a to a
degree yeah I mean three one and three
two really are wrapped up together
um we've reviewed the contents of the
report and we will we will take those
views onto cabinet on third of them
emphasize ready in 3.2 isn't it the
verbal recommendations to the cabinet
yeah
which will take on
taking on board all the comments that
have been made about parking schools and
everything else
here on if you if you're taking verbal
recommendations we need to be clear that
the committee have agreed those verbal
recommendations if they're comments that
everybody's made absolutely fine but if
you're recommending to Cabinet then you
need to get the approval of the
committee
I think councilor problems are talking
rather more about
comments rather than recommendations
because there are so many aspects that
we could get involved in as I drew the
analogy of the of the iceberg with a
little bit sticking out the top which is
what we've got here there's so much
underneath that we we couldn't possibly
make recommendations for cabinet at this
stage we could we could make
if we made a recommendation it would be
to look at something in a bit more
detail
oh well I suppose yes we have to make
put that on the list
so cabinet you could ask cabinet to look
at how to reduce car parking demand and
look at areas where they have done so
successfully as part of the
implementation plan
and also the way in which parents
transport their children to school and
pedestrian access once part you could
ask cabinet to make sure that that's
included in any implementation
yeah
thank you chair I have a couple of
recommendations written down too
um the the one that dresses the short
distance
um that further Works undertaking for
officers to review evidence to address
short uh distance car Journeys from from
other authorities who have successfully
made alternative arrangement to replace
or change car parking arrangements to
support the implementation plan
oh that's I just think that you need to
propose in a second to the absolutely
committee absolutely so I have three
recommendations written down so far and
these are to remote to replace
them yes yes
so um 3.2 where it says verbal comments
because the chairs we'll put the verbal
comments but we'll put a formal
recommendation as well as part of that
which all we're going to agree yeah
could you read this out for us yes I
have rejected the recommendations a
little bit so um do bear with me so I
have 1.1 that you joined overview and
screw to committee note the content of
the report and that a verbal
presentation of the comment made as this
meeting be provided to cabinet
1.2 that joint oou and scrutiny ask the
report be provided to the committee in
due course to review the progress on the
parking strategy implementation plan
and then 1.3 that further Works under
undertaken by officers to review
evidence to address short distance car
Journeys from
um
from other authorities who have
successfully made alternative
arrangements to replace car parking
arrangement to support the
implementation plan now you might want
to reword the
and I actually preferred Jan's version
[Laughter]
thank you
so I
just um just put my glasses on so that I
can see
um
but the recommendation to Cabinet is
that they ask cabinet to look at um as
part of the implementation plan reducing
car parking demand looking at areas
where they have done so successfully in
other places the way in which parents
transport their children to school and
pedestrian access once parked
um to ensure
um there are other methods to get to
other places I've thought but I didn't
need that at the end just that bit
does that cover everything is that okay
she only wants to come back yeah and
that last one I'm not sure that's
something that we can really influence
within the parking strategy
it is
okay so
it's not part of that strategy so we'd
have to remove that one fair enough
so we're looking at reducing car parking
demands at areas where they have gone so
successfully and leave it at that and
then perhaps those areas can be looked
at you know parking outside school and
that sort of thing as part of that
recommendation and just keep it to the
one simple recommendation reduce car
parking demands looking at areas where
they have gone so successfully in other
places just hold on a second
I could go with that if it was
um slightly changed to maybe replacing
car park demand so it's not suggesting
to
reduce footfall on a town
do you see what I mean that's yeah
that's the only issue and I think um the
council makes a really good point with
that and that's definitely something we
should be looking at but um for me the
football on the town is so important
that we've got to I don't want it to be
some
you know squeeze in anything
so just a tweak then and then in line
with that to that so
um rather than reducing to look at it
was something about to look at other
areas would they have done so six weeks
yeah so it was to start off to reduce
carbon demand maybe we want to look at
other areas that have reduced car
parking
um and or replaced car parking with
alternative with alternatives
um so that so that um because that
because
yeah that I think that's does that
capture it I just replaced that
technology
I think I think we can agree to work
with something
suffer two points I just don't think we
can have the obligation to make the
difference because it's not it's not
within our gift so the school parking
and the um
Street
uh
point that was made earlier we can we
can work with them to review but we
can't lead that conversation because
it's not in our gift
we were just going to do the top one
anyway Fiona ire which was the we just
reducing looking at car parking demand
where other areas have done so
successfully
uh thank you chair the the the the third
of the thing the points the one that you
were thinking that you would cross out
because
um officers can't influence the purpose
of that was
um around uh the districts manage the
car parks
the districts might need to provide
either a new car park or to
somehow get more spaces or different
spaces within their car Parks but by
the
the drift of it was to ensure that when
as part of our maintenance and
management of our car Parks we look at
ways
for people to get through the car park
for making them safe for pedestrians I
have seen car parks that have just had
the number of spaces
increased to such a degree that it's
almost impossible to walk safely from
one side of the car park to the ticket
machine and back again and then to the
shop so it's all it's all around the way
we manage
our car Parks that's what that was
intended to be
that that isn't that feels like a
comment you might want to make a cabinet
rather than necessarily something which
comes out of
this particular Port which was all
around the evidence and the development
of the strategy I can understand it's a
really valid comment but it doesn't feel
to me like it's quite relevant to what
you're being asked to look at in terms
of the evidence base and the development
of the strategy itself
sorry
um but I can only make that comment if
if my colleagues agree that it's a
comment that they want me to make
you can make comments it's the formal
recommendations to cabinet that we just
need to narrow down here yeah
I had wondered as well
sorry bear me two seconds
ah
could we
make a recommendation that's for if this
reports Works
um as
integrated connectivity with neighboring
strategies such as that is be idling
reduction which is being looked at if we
are doing going part of this is to
change signage
signage if there's going to be put no
item signs could we look at that as well
so if we're doing this report there's
another report somewhere else could have
been should we ensure integration and
connectivity
um and enough
comes under contact a comment sorry that
go before the cabinet we can provide
okay rather than being a recommendation
yeah and we part of this I know this
um disabled parking does come underneath
a different roommate could we make the
comments about placement of disabled car
parking where
car parks at the moment which have the
wrong
placement are not being used and so
people aren't are either parking
elsewhere and making an impact on the
these
example being such as the Regal Car Park
placement in the Stow Market where far
car Parks but cannot be used for
disabled access because it's been taken
over by the uh the charging points which
would have been used elsewhere so could
it be you could it be I think it might
be probably a comment comment I think
again then yeah but a very valid comment
yeah
sorry I'm trying to thank you but I'll
get words out eventually
you okay yeah can someone turn off my
mic please I just can't get my hand to
work sorry
okay right anything else that as far as
modifications to the recommendations
concerned
cool I think I'm I'd like to just be
absolutely clear what are the
recommendations
if we got rid of all the possible
alterations to it then we can look at uh
have them read back to us and that we
can decide where we go from there and
then my I I have a question is how do we
note which comments are going to be
taken to Cabinet by you gentlemen
I think if we can have another
two-hour discussion on what the comments
are going to be together
yeah yeah
oh yeah oh yeah yeah yes okay
yeah yeah I'm not trying to hide
anything
in fact I'll try again should we try and
I'll read back let's do it at least
we have 1.1 that you joined overview and
scrutiny committee note the content of
the report and that a verbal
presentation of the comments made at
this meeting be provided to cabinets
okay
1.2 that work is undertaken to replace
car parking demands with Alternatives by
looking at other areas that have done so
successfully
yeah
1.3 that the overview and scrutiny
committee asks that the report be
provided to the committee in due course
to review the progress on the parking
strategy in parking strategy
implementation plan
you know everything
if you're happy with those do you know
somebody recommend them
to wear this
move on then to the electronic voting
thank you
councilor Lindsay
no problem no problem
Council Lindsay maybe just ask for your
vote again please
thank you sorry
thank you Chad that is eight votes for
that's correct
thank you very much indeed thank you
very much indeed
Sarah and Sarah
um
councilor Fleming yes
I'm surprised
yes I think we should have a short break
I think we're sorry to keep
the finance team here for so long but
we'll just we'll just have a quick five
minute break
for uh Comfort adjustment
foreign
shared revenues partnership council tax
reduction scheme
I'd like to
is councilor Busby going to say anything
to start off with or are you joining in
later on
right so in that case I would like to
invite Rebecca Hewitt to
I believe you're making a presentation
good morning
counselors um this report sets out
proposed changes to the working age
council tax reduction scheme for your
feedback and consideration could you get
a little bit closer to the microphone
please this this report sets out
proposed changes to the working age
council tax reduction scheme for your
feedback and consideration before going
to cabinet
current scheme provides for a reduction
of up to 95 percent
this report sets out four options for
consideration
first to take the maximum reduction up
to 100 percent
secondly having a reduction up to a
hundred percent for households receiving
Legacy benefits and then a simplified
scheme for Universal Credit customers
up and third option up to 100 maximum
reduction with a simplified scheme for
Universal Credit customers and
transitional relief option four to stay
the same
we have Amy Mays and Andrew Wilcock from
the shared revenues partnership with us
today and Amy has a presentation to take
you through the proposed changes
that's it
this presentation will hopefully explain
to councilors why we needed to consider
a new scheme for council tax reduction
and it will take you through the
proposals which you're asked to consider
in making recommendations and comments
to cabinet
so council tax reduction replaces the
council tax benefits scheme that we had
in place from the introduction of
council tax in 1993 until 2013.
council tax benefit itself offered a
hundred percent benefit to the poorest
households
on the introduction of council tax
reduction
at that time a working age local scheme
was recommended to commence a reduction
rate at 91.5
in baber it was introduced at 91.5
percent and in mid-suffolk it was
introduced at a rate of 95 reduction
the pension age scheme has always
offered 100 reduction
on the introduction of Universal Credit
in 2018 we needed to amend the scheme to
include those customers who were going
to be newly in receipt of Universal
Credit
and so we had an opportunity to amend it
and at that point both schemes were
aligned to award a 95 reduction to
council tax
now the scheme itself
is very much based on the old council
tax benefit scheme which mirrors the
housing benefit rules and regulations
in so much as it is and means tested
scheme and we need to gather evidence of
everybody's income and capital and make
a comparison against an applicable
amount that's set by the government
that in itself is quite an exhaustive
process and can be quite intrusive for
customers however because that is a
scheme we are required to undertake for
housing benefit it works very well for
customers who receive both housing
benefit and council tax reduction
since the introduction of Universal
Credit there has been a need for people
to migrate from housing benefit to
housing costs which is paid from
Universal Credit and the resulting issue
is that for those who receive only
council tax reduction that we undertake
an exhaustive means test for what is the
application of a discount
now we talk a little about admin the
administrative burden but for customers
on Universal Credit there is a
requirement for them to review their
income on a monthly basis and where in
their income fluctuates if they're on a
zero hours contract that can mean that a
recalculation of their Universal Credit
happens every month and consequently a
means test adjustment for CTR
that leads to new council tax bills
calculations of installments and often
leads to confusion for customers
the requirement that everybody pays at
least five percent means that there are
small balances to collect from everybody
regardless of their household income
but they added complication for us is
that big because there is a need to
review people's incomes and capital that
it can't be automated so it is quite
administratively
heavy in the information that we have to
collect
so customers themselves quite often
don't know what they need to pay or when
they need to pay it
for Universal Credit as soon as where
they get an adjustment they get a new
bill and a new installment plan and just
as they're getting ready to pay their
first installment it recalculates and
starts again
so we do receive an Administration
subsidy for
awarding council tax reduction but it's
equivalent to 16 pounds a per case per
year
now when we were just calculating an
annual entitlement and we were doing
that once as part of the annual billing
process and the new council tax setting
that covered the costs but with
Universal Credit we're seeing the need
to recalculate on a monthly basis and
the cost to administer is now falling
short in subsidy of what it actually
costs the authorities to run
in addition to that there are other
costs for printing posting and then the
need to undertake recovery action for
customers with small balances
so the the options that we've brought on
the table are
um
in the first instance to look at moving
from the 95 reduction to 100 reduction
that takes us back to where we were when
council tax benefit was in place
it means that everybody will be better
off
who's in currently in receipt of council
tax reduction because they will benefit
from the five percent uplift in the
reduction rate
it will reduce the number of people with
small balances that we need to recover
from
and it introduces Equity then with the
pension age scheme which offers 100
reduction
the difficulty with doing that step
alone is that it won't help with the
administration issues we will still need
to keep count recalculating for
customers on Universal Credit and
customers will still be confused as to
what to pay how often to pay when they
can pay
um there are some minimal costs
obviously from increasing the cost of
the scheme
and um the costs are there
for you to consider
so if we want to do a little bit more
than that and look at the cost of the
administration
then we need to do something a little
more complex
so option two introduces a banded scheme
for those customers on Universal Credit
which will reduce the administrative
churn
in some matches that with use of
abandoned income those customers who
have minimal change in their earnings
will not require recalculation at all
it also reduces those numbers of people
who we have to
calculating entitlement to just those
customers who are on universal credit
with earnings so those customers who
were in receipt of Universal Credit but
have personal Independence payments will
receive
full council tax reduction
it will reduce the number of bills that
we need to send it will reduce the
number of times we recalculate it it
will encourage those people who have
have earnings level at the lower or
midpoint ranges to be able to increase
their earnings without detriment or fear
of loss of council tax and introduces
some Equity as well so regardless of the
council tax that that person pays the
amount that they will be asked to
contribute will be the same because of
their income not because of where they
live
there is a further Con in samachas to
introduce that kind of a scheme there
will be additional costs
and some customers because of the
midpoint range will be
receiving less
council tax reduction on implementation
than they would have been had we
continued on the old scheme
so option three really carries on the
same scheme as it was in option two but
introduces transitional protection so on
implementation no customer suffers a
detriment
in all other regards the scheme is the
same but because we're looking to
support those customers who would have
lost money under option two there is a
further cost
option four is we don't have to change
the scheme there is no compulsion other
than we have an opportunity to review it
now cost of living certainly is it is a
real issue and a hot topic
so we've got an opportunity to look at
it simplify the scheme or not an option
four allows the
to continue as is
so included here is a draft timeline
what councilors are asked to do at the
moment is to put forward their
recommendations and comments for cabinet
and cabinet will be asked to um
give permission to go out for
consultation
there will be a six-week consultation
public consultation running until the
24th of November and then we will look
to review
the findings of the consultation and
take another report back to cabinet for
a decision about implementation
um there are two dates there as to when
that decision could be made
but if it were to be implemented it
would take effect from April 23.
so there is an opportunity for custom
sorry for counselors to ask questions
thank you very much indeed uh questions
cancel the Carter we'll start with down
at the front
oh I'm sorry it was
he's deferring to you councilor I do but
thank you
um I did have a query well I do lovely
with um customer when you're born shop
and you have a chance of leaving it
leaving the streets but regardless
um
uh this report specifically refers to
Universal Credit
and it's not just people on universal
credits who do have reduction
what about Legacy benefits or
interdependent beds if we were to go for
a passport scheme would it also include
say personal independent payments would
include other benefits are still being
paid due to ongoing disability Awards
um or would just be involved with
different scheme to handle those
and give you a question currently the
intention is to just deal with the the
um difficulties that we're then
um encountered with Universal Credit the
universe sorry the Legacy scheme will
continue and it will continue until such
time as those customers are transferred
onto Universal Credit at which point the
Universal Credit scheme will take over
currently we're anticipating that the
migration from housing benefit
to housing costs will take place for
working age customers during the year of
2024 so it's likely that we will see a
move of customers as they have
um
significant changes as we've seen
currently or at the point that a managed
migration takes place so the idea is
that we change the scheme to allow all
customers to move on to a scheme which
will Flex with them as they move on to
Universal Credit
I'd say some 2026 in some cases but
certainly
um as we're part of a shared revenues
partnership what does the other council
do
um
currently Ipswich are out for
consultation on the same basis of this
scheme in an ideal world it would be
great if the three authorities had the
same scheme not just because it makes it
administratively easier for us because
actually the system would deal with that
so we could have different income bans
or different rates of contribution for
each of the authorities but for our
customers I think who we often see move
between the districts and the borough
it's much easier if we can remain
consistent so IPS which are out for
consultation now
it's on the basis of the same scheme and
that that consultation will close on the
15th of November
we're a little bit further behind
um for baber and mid suffolks
consultation but obviously we will look
at the consultation
results across the piece when we come to
make those final recommendations
yeah thanks um
do Ipswich have a preferred option
already or are all four options out for
consultation
ipswich's preferred option is for option
three in this instance
to be an awful lot between the
and there was obviously in in my mind it
was between one and two but it's
interesting that they've gone
and I think option two has more Pros
um and the slightly cons
and given what you've said about prefer
to have a level you know everyone being
the same what what is what a conclusion
of the officers of of your team come to
about the preferred option
my recommendation is for option three
for the ease of implementation
and
with a transitional protection scheme we
can look
to have protection on introduction
and then we can look for people to lose
transitional protection once they become
better off under the new scheme we can
look to meet the shortfall for longer
periods or we can look to give them less
of a reduction from a for a greater
period and it all comes down to cost but
we do have the flexibility at that point
to make choices based on the cost and
the desire of the authorities to support
those customers in transition
foreign
so
in each of these first three options
there are costs associated and those
one-off costs are recurring costs it's
my first question then with regard to
option two uh you indicated that there
would be a few
people who were mocked who were worse
off
how would you deal with them and finally
I understood that
you thought that automation was not a
means by which we might automate
or deal with the administrative
processes involved
which seems
counter-intuitive to me because the more
transactions that you need to deal with
on a regular basis the the better
to it could be managed with an automated
process so I'd like to get your thinking
on that
I'll try and try and cover all of the
counselor's points in terms of the
recurrent costs once we've started
supporting people at a level there will
be a requirement year on year to to
cover them the continuing costs of the
scheme
so moving from a 95 scheme to 100 scheme
will increase the scheme costs
moving to a banded scheme because more
customers receive 100 reduction
will incur costs and it will incur costs
year on year
terms of the cost though because of the
potential for administrative savings
it's possible that actually we will save
an Administration what we are expending
in additional support for customers
for those customers who are currently
worse off under option two The Proposal
is to introduce a transitional
protection scheme which is option three
the alternative would be that we just
accept that some people are worse off
and obviously that makes it quite
difficult to implement a scheme without
um
public
remark
the question about automation
um
maybe I wasn't very clear when I was
talking you through that
but currently we have to gather lots of
information we have to see lots of
information before we can make an
assessment
the way that the new scheme will work is
that we will be able to receive direct
from the DWP electronic notices of
people's Universal Credit entitlement
and any earnings element and the
computer will read that we won't put it
through a second second means test we
won't subject those customers to a
further process and as such we will be
able to take the benefit of that
automation possibility
hi
um
what do you um what do we know about the
harm that that five percent doing to um
people on um UC and that um because what
I'm what I'm thinking about here is um
we need to understand what difference
that five percent makes
um and what difference
um taking it away the cost away makes
because
um we've got administrative costs but
there's also money for the County
Council
and they they do desperately need the
money and um over 10 years in
mid-suffolk that's
1.4 million pounds that's lost in them
in um
tax coming in over over all the
different
um authorities that receive it
um and it does worry me
that okay that's our administrative cost
um but also this is this this could be
quite crucially important money in you
know looking after um people adult
social care children child care and
all these different aspects so um what
I'm what I'm basically trying to um
weigh up
is the harm that that five percent is
doing to the people that are paying it
now compared with the potential 1.4
million over 10 years of Lost
income
I think I think the answer is the
expectation is that people pay that five
percent the reality is that we're asking
for people to pay who don't have the
means to pay so there is an anticipation
that we're generating an income the
reality is that we're accruing a debt
are you saying a social debt
um is that sorry just a
tax itself it's so unpaid
we have large large amount of money
that's unpaid because we're unable to
collect from people who don't have the
means to pay oh sorry yeah no sorry I
understand yeah I understand exactly
what you're saying so it's not that's
not necessarily what's been generated at
all those figures there okay okay thank
you
foreign
thank you chair
um
I think looking from your point of view
are you talking about the 1.4 million am
I right that that would be somewhere
around one pound per person per annum uh
that that we might be not putting into
the public purse
um you you stated the figure I'm just
trying to get a feel for what it is
in the form of a question can I just ask
the question that about the additional
costs
um you gave us the additional costs for
the various options the three options do
they take account of uh Savings in
administration
um and the other question is uh
is the uncertain
is the uncertainty around when to pay
and how much to pay from our customer's
point of view one of the real social
Savings of
introducing options one two or
particularly option three
the additional costs
um
in the report don't take into account
any admin savings at the time
the way that the partnership
contributions are worked out are worked
out annually in retrospect based on the
churn
it is true that reducing the churn will
reduce the cost on the authority to
undertake the administration
in terms of the uncertainty options two
and three will allow customers on
Universal Credit to receive a bill
at the start of the year and not receive
repeat bills every time the Universal
Credit is recalculated so it certainly
reduces the uncertainty for customers
thank you
thank you Chad and that's really clear
to understand thank you very much
Rebecca one of my concerns is
um
in Sudbury we have quite a few people
who find it very difficult to understand
things particularly if it's using a
computer and so at the moment we have
your staff at an access point for two
days a week and I'm wondering early days
when this has changed would it be
possible to maybe have an extra day in
Sudbury Library at the moment it's
Mondays and Thursdays and we have a bank
holiday they only have one day yes it
would be more admin costs but some of
the people that we deal with they still
we get at least 40 a week still going to
the town hall because they they really
just don't get it and I'm talking about
people that do have difficulties
learning difficulties and some of our
elderly so I just wondered if that could
be considered and I think option three
sounds really sensible do you understand
what I'm trying to to say
just interject there I think that is
outside of what we're we're discussing
today the the frequency of visits to uh
to Sudbury but I'm sure it's something
that uh the portfolio holder for finance
will take on board uh as a comment from
from there
um but that doesn't stop your so the
last part of your question being put
forward
I say I take on board the comments there
and we can certainly share that
experience as part of the consultation
um customer services actually deal with
the front of house
shared revenues partnership just deals
with the calculation and in this element
we're a back office service only but
it's a very relevant Point thank you
um just coming back to the point
councilor Carson was making about
the sums of money involved
so if I've understood your response
correctly
um the the five percent
he thinks we're going to lose we're
actually already losing
um so actually in the last Financial
year
what was that sum of money
secondly uh if we're not if it's a bad
debt in this in essence
that we're not collecting what is the
council's
methodology for writing that off uh in
the account because I'm not come across
that in looking at our accounts in the
last four years
I'll ask my colleague Mr Wilcox to deal
with that as he is the Mr council tax
show about the title I mean in
I guess from accounts tax perspective
the CTR comes across as a discount so
when we look at what's left in arrears
it's very difficult to distinguish what
relates to CTR accounts or normal counts
taxpayers
um
certainly for
figures
last year
is that the end of the financial year
for last year's debt alone for for baby
it was just under 1.2 million pounds
worth of arrears and for mid-suffolk
um
ironically just under 1.2 million pounds
worth of arrays but we do have rules
that go back some years so
for
um you know we will endeavor to try and
collect
over a period of time until such time as
perhaps it becomes uneconomical to
collect or
the individual who's gone down the route
with a debt relief order or bankruptcy
so
I guess some of it we will collect over
time some of it won't and it could be
built into that bad division that was
calculated by Finance
um
at the end of the year our overall
collection
is around about
98.3 within year where we have been able
to to look at CTI cases we probably get
about 75 in year but then what we have
to do for non-payment is you know go
down that recovery route and try and
work with customers at worst case
scenario we end up with an attachment
which you know 3.75 a week
can take some time
to collect but you know the bad debt
provision discount as I say calculated
by Finance does appear in the statement
accounts and they will look at the level
of Reason how many years they go back
um
Rebecca in terms of how you calculate
the bad debt provision can you fill that
Gap
um I don't have that information to hand
at the moment about how that's
calculated and what that value is but I
can certainly take it away
because the Carter
thank you
I know that we are dealing with
residents who cannot currently afford to
pay and I know that there are Services
out there who are helping we do offer um
some measures and we do try to help our
residents who count we can't pay
so I'm not saying that we would go down
this route but if we were to take legal
action to date recovery or if we were to
eventually it could cause it could be
imprisonment if you don't pay a Payless
what would be the cost so we have a
figure
what are our legal costs if we went down
that route
so it's I just want to get in mind so we
have a sum of money what debt would cost
we would have
if we went down this legal route and how
much we'd be saving we're saving by not
having to go down this route and could
we also reach out to our external bodies
who work like such as Satan's advice who
have teams who deal with individuals who
cannot pay the council tax and actually
have sessions where they go in and help
with the monitoring could we ask them
how much money they are spending on a
weekly basis to actually assist higher
residents who cannot pay so we can put
this as well a cost that by having this
measure in place versus the amount of
money we're not only saving ourselves in
admin fees not only saving ourselves by
not having to go down this legal debt
collection route and also for my money
while saving our bodies but currently
are struggling themselves and are having
to help our residents because
whatever means either we're not doing it
or they need to help
so this is a way of going by option
three or not even only saving ourselves
we're saving the local residents and the
local community
if we have those figures if I could just
come in there I think probably what
we've got there is a a series of
questions to produce some information
that we don't have to hand which could
come out in the consultation for a six
week period for whatever option we go
for because we're going to have to have
a six-week consultation period and the
evidence could be collected for you
for you to be able to include that
within the consultation and that's
something in the officers wish to add
anything to that
I was just going to write I mean similar
lines as part of the consultation we
will be talking to the citizens advice
and we will gather their views on you
know what they're experiencing and the
costs and we can you know counter that
with I guess what it's costing us to
collect per case as well
yeah um first of all I'd like to thank
the officers for the report because it's
very concise also the member briefing
was very very useful that gave us a lot
of background as well so thank you for
that um unless other members have got
comments I'd like to propose that we we
accept the recommendation and with
option three as the preferred option
unless there's strong opposition till
now
do you have a second for that
quite a few hands on up right
before we go into further further into
debate has anybody got any other
questions
don't want to leave anybody thinking I
haven't had my question answered
because it just just just
um the question yeah no absolutely
um the uh there's been some questions
about the costs and Council cast them
rightly
says that we've got to look at the cost
to the other authorities like the County
Council
today
um
presumably they get a say in the
consultation but do they actually
if say our cabinets approve at the
district level approve the um option
three say does it does the County
Council have to Cabinet have to approve
it as well or do they just we we
basically have the decision Powers not
not the counting
[Music]
again
um
as one of the stakeholders Suffolk
County will feed into that consultation
but I mean ultimately it will be a
district decision you know it will go
for full Council decision
thank you very much I just wondered what
the um Finance portfolio holders view
was on this at this stage would that be
appropriate
and when he wants to commit himself
before the cabinet meeting on Monday
well yeah my my view is quite simple uh
I always think that we should aim for
maximum benefit at minimum cost
I don't see any point in spending a
thousand pounds trying to click 10.
um
and the more we can simplify any system
it'll make it much easier for to
understand
and for people to pay the funds we won't
need to tie up the cab try to explain
our complicated systems so I think
everything we can do to make it simpler
fairer
and more beneficial
we should do it and I believe that the
administrative costs that will be
reduced as a result of making it simpler
or probably more
any loss that we'd like to make
I think the portfolio holder for
finances succinctly sort of
encapsulated quite a lot of what might
have been there in in debate does
anybody have anything else to say before
we move to but we've had a proposal
that's been seconded
for option three
Lindsay Lindsay scarf Ayers we should
take you back
so please
has anybody anything else to
to say on the debate
then we'll move to the electronic vote
oh sorry
all right I I I'd like you to just pick
up on what councilor Busby was saying
because
um it does seem to me that
um the recommendations coming from the
officers this morning with regard to
this are quite sound uh and and anything
we can do to make it a smoother less
complex system the better it is having
had to deal with some residents lately I
have to say some of the communication
from this Council
and I I think I can read
um I've been extremely difficult to
follow and understand
um and the fact that you know
potentially people could be getting five
or six
Communications effectively about the
same thing in the same Financial period
is quite daunting for many people to to
get their heads around so I I mean I
think you know in looking at this we
should bear that sort of thing in your
mind and I also
um would I mean I know it's not part of
this remit because you're not the front
facing but I think this issue of access
to the access point if you if you pardon
the tautology it is really important
because I think that there just isn't
enough face time for people to really
completely get their concerns resolved
in a timely fashion
um and I think the other side of this
coin is looking at that
thank you
the recommendation does does talk about
uh to make comments and recommendations
for Council well the recommendation is
for option three one of the comments can
certainly be that the access to FaceTime
with advisors on these issues should be
increased
I'm not going to comment on that
so can I just um clarify the options
we're considering in now are what we
consult on
in the future there's not a
recommendation because obviously we need
that consultation before we're making a
recommendation to cabinet cabinet then
make a decision on what is going to go
out to consultation what goes off to
consultation it's not a decision on what
option we would prefer in the long term
it's a option on what goes out to um
consultation
sorry I'll leave that to the offices to
unravel I'm just trying to get it clear
we're looking
to agree a period of consultation not to
implement a scheme so we will have then
a six-week consultation period at which
time we'll come back we'll review and we
will report back to cabinet and then to
full Council for a decision on whether a
scheme is implemented
no thank you that's what I thought but I
was just making sure that I knew what I
was voting for
thank you chair that weight is now in
progress
might take you away
thank you chair there's nine points for
that's unanimous
that has been canceled
I think we move on then to item nine on
the agenda Jos stroke 22 stroke 10
information bulletin shared Legal
Services performance monitoring and the
splitted new legal matters
I'd like to invite Nigel
would you do Leanne dulu sorry beg your
pardon thank you to introduce the
information to the committee
sorry
counselor casting oh yes
sorry Mr chairman I'm I'm terribly sorry
I've got an event for my Chairman's
charity
um this afternoon that starts at two
o'clock and I I'm getting to the point
now where I won't have a lot of well any
buffer time in between going and to the
event and organizing it and getting home
first and just gonna hurt
um with your permission may I um leave
the meeting at this point I don't know
what would happen if I didn't get my
permission but yes certainly of course
I'm staying until the end of the meeting
you may be excused
thank you
I hope it's a successful event
thank you chair good morning councilors
I'm here on behalf of Teresa Halliday
the service manager for the the legal
service and information governance
um service
um she was unable to attend today so I'm
here to present the uh the bulletin on
her behalf
um just giving a quick bit of background
um in November last year this committee
made a decision for an information
bulletin to be presented to confirm the
recharging mechanism for the the cost of
the legal service and to provide
comparative data and to provide data
showing the split between the work
carried out for baber and and
mid-suffolk councils and bulletin before
you today that was with your papers
um is is there to illustrate that that
split
uh the steering board for the legal
service reviews uh the legal service
performance data on a sixth monthly
basis and that's using data from the
case management system on and provides
information on the number of new legal
instructions received from each
Authority and to which legal team those
instructions are going
the percentage of complexity levels
assigned to new legal instructions per
Authority and a year by year comparison
on legal instructions and complexity
levels per Authority as well
uh if you look at the report at page 34
um the pie chart at the top of that page
shows uh some recent Trends from the
financial year of 2020-21 and and shows
a relatively even split between
instructions from West Suffolk Council
and baber mid-suffolk it's a 5149 split
slightly in favor of where Suffolk
Council
however the split does not provide any
details as to the complexity or the time
resource required to deal with these
instructions
and there is a this is demonstrated on a
complexity shot which I'll refer to in a
moment or two
also until April 22 April this year it
was not possible to determine whether
instructions came from baber or
mid-suffolk we we just had babe around
mid-suffolk instructions
um contained in the data but that has
changed slightly
um you will notice that the the pie
chart does show some split it's like a
12 for baber and a 10 for mid-suffolk
these are matters that are were opened
um during that year but are still
ongoing so the the data has been able to
been updated and inputted into the
system which Council actually supplied
those instructions
then the second pie chart on that page
shows a breakdown of the instructions by
legal team within the service it doesn't
tell the whole story is the nature of
instructions for different teams of
areas for example the litigation team
deals with a large number of of standard
instructions such as debt recovery and
property repossessions whereas the
commercial team tend to deal with more
bespoke instructions which may relate to
to long-term projects
onto the actual um workload that can be
ascertained by assigning a a complexity
score this is a very simple system that
we use as you can see from the chart at
the top of page 35 is a simple scoring
system it's just sufficient to
demonstrate the nature of instructions
in respect of the time and the level of
expertise needed to complete those tasks
and it's calculated by scoring on two
scales of time and expertise resulting
in a complexity score of one to seven
for example complexity one will be a
task that can be carried out by a junior
team member it'll take no more than a
week to complete and usually with little
uh or no research required
at the other end of the scale you'll
have a complexity seven matter which
will be a very complex issue with
significant consequences for the council
financially corporately and reputational
usually these tasks are undertaken by a
senior member of the team with
sufficient post-qualification experience
or by a team of officers and it will
continue for a period of over three
months
and uh and I think it's it's quite clear
to see you
the type of matters that fall in between
the second graph on page 35 is a
breakdown of the complexity score and
these are for instructions received in
2021
and they demonstrate the difference in
complexity scores for instructions from
the different councils
for example if you look at the the row
of complexity seven at the bottom of
that chart you'll see that Baba
mid-suffolk actually have a combined
number of 99 instructions of that
complexity whereas West Suffolk Council
only had 53 instructions for that level
and and this is despite there being
slightly more instructions coming from
West Suffolk Council so you can see that
it demonstrates that just when you see
the the split on the pie chart that's
not necessarily that the time and
resource that's being put into those
those councils and it could vary
going over the page to the top of page
36 there's a
pie chart which shows the instructions
from 2021 and 22. again West Suffolk
Council accounts for more there's 56 of
the total but as stated before it
doesn't necessarily mean that legal
service has devoted more time or
resources on West Suffolk Council than
on baber and mid-suffolk councils
and also from that chart you'll note
that there's a fairly even split of
instructions from baber and mid-suffolk
the second pie chart shows a similar
breakdown between the teams within the
legal service you'll notice there is a
significant rise in property
instructions but this is mainly because
of the way that the the instructions
have been recorded for example the
property team get a lot of boundary
inquiries they did have a general file
on on our case management system just
for boundary inquiries but it you know
through trial and error we've decided
that it's better to open a new meta for
each one which is why there is a a
higher number but not necessarily many
different in the actual workload being
passed to that team
um the complexity chart for 20 21 22
shows a reduction in the higher
complexity scores but as you can see
baber mid-suffolk generally have a
higher number of complexity uh sort of
scored instructions than West Suffolk
Council
so that that trend is has continued
and and then finally we have the data
from the First Financial quarter of this
year which shows a similar breakdown
between West Suffolk Council and babe
and mid Suffolk councils but this is the
first quarter we've been able to show
the full split between baber and
mid-suffolk and and as you can see it
demonstrates a very even split in
numbers between those councils
um where the the instructions haven't
been split these are matters that are
the instructions are from jointly both
councils for example my time here today
I'm working with the joint committees um
there may be projects that both councils
are working on and obviously there's
legal input to that so they are they are
down as a um as a joint labor
mid-suffolk
um statistic
I'm happy to answer any questions that
you have I may have to defer to the the
Steering group steering board or to uh
Trader the service manager and we'll
certainly get back to you but if you
have any questions now for me I'll
happily try to answer them for you
thank you chair well before you get
bogged down with too many legal
questions from the from the from the
team here just one quick one looking at
the top of page 37 where it's talking
about the complexity split for 2122 the
fact the numbers have
complexity sevens has dropped right off
is that because those are those new
instructions or could it be that it's
just that there's an awful lot of old
ones that are clogging up the system no
these will be new instructions
um it could be the number of sevens
being in investigate it could be
considerably higher it could be it's
it's never going to be a a level graph
with these matters we do have periods
where they all seem to come up once and
you know the the big projects and things
like that
so the the level of complexity seven
inquiries of drastically fallen down
for whatever reason but
um the ones that we've had before so
that would be in the chart on page 35
there were
a significant number over a hundred
what how are they progressing I mean if
they are they reducing
even though we've got some new ones and
the second part of my question is
um although the the splits on new
instructions fairly even between West
Suffolk and
paper and mid-safar
um are the costs associated on the same
level
um in answer to your
first question I've I really don't know
we'd have to drill down into the um the
data to get that kind of information for
you as to what's happening with
um you know the high complexity matters
um respect to the second one that is an
easier question to answer and the answer
it is it is generally an even split
um we are your in-house legal service we
do not actually charge
for each individual matter we have to
try and record that we have a case
management system and and that's what we
do but we don't actually recharge the
only recharge that happens is between
the two councils and that's because
um some of the members of the legal team
are employed by West Suffolk Council
other members are employed by labor
mid-suffolk and as you can imagine it's
not a 50 50 split it changes and varies
and so there's obviously some
complicated calculations that go between
the two councils that so so that they
kind of pay each other to make sure that
they are getting their fair share and
paying for their fair share of the legal
service
I hope that answers your question
yeah thanks to Nigel that does answer
those questions but I guess
um
is the trend towards more or less
litigation then
the the trouble with the and litigation
is is my team I'm the the business
partner for that team the trouble with
litigation is that uh it tends to
capture everything that doesn't fall
under all the other matters that are you
know property planning and
and uh sort of commercial we do tend to
catch the the left field instructions
sometimes and we do assist the other
teams like we will assist the planning
um team with enforcement matters and
things like that and also with the
property team we assist them with
um with repossessions and things like
that and certainly for some types of
things so it is it is quite fluid we
have this this Matrix working where we
will you know we don't season our silos
and just
do what what's in our area we we do
actually work across the team where
where we can we do have quite a
good range of Noise Within the legal
service
but it's
it it always changes
I'll have a period where I'm doing
nothing but licensing hearings
and then it'll be on to
a sort of criminal action where we
prosecute for health and safety and and
food safety and things like that so it's
there's never a typical period where
we're getting the same things all the
time it's uh it changes Ebbs and flows
just one one point I'd just like to ask
and that is
this is this gives us a lot of detail
about the
the workload which is on
the on the shared legal team
what is the churn-like in terms of staff
because we hear about that a lot in the
in the Press of legal teams changing and
all the rest of it it's pretty good
actually we're I I think we are
basically all our posts are filled at
the moment that there's always comings
and goings but we I we've not had an
issue over the last couple of years
where we've had gaps in Services it's
something that's always being looked at
it's always under review as it is right
across the council with all all dive
experts and and teams but I think if
Teresa was here I'm sure she would give
quite a glowing reporting that we have
quite a good success in Recruitment and
we certainly have done over the last uh
two or three years
and thank you chair um
have I got this right it looks as if
from
2020 to 21 and then compare 21 22 with
that the number of matters
um given to you by mid-suffolk baber by
baber and Midsouth and by babe Midsouth
joint matters has pretty well been the
same over the two years but
um
the number of matters
uh the number of instructions from West
Africa has gone up by 20 percent
uh and it looks as if that that trend is
continuing
um
is is that like am I am I am I am I
right I I think I think I am
um and also the complexity of the
Matters from uh mid-suffolk and baber
and paper mid Suffolk
um has gone down from one year to the
next
if I'm right just does that at some
point perhaps at the end of the
financial year or during the financial
year after that does that somehow
um manifest itself in uh in financial
terms
that'll be a question I'll have to refer
to the the to the steering board
um it's
it's difficult to say because
like I say we have started
um changing the way we accept
instructions for example with the
property ones the numbers have gone up
but the work hasn't actually gone up
it's more or less the same
um I I couldn't really answer you as to
respect in respect of whether we are
gradually spending more time with
Suffolk matters or with babe amid
Suffolk from my experience I'd say no
but I can't speak for for the other
teams
um and
um
with regards to the complexities going
down
again it's impossible for me to to
actually sort of give an answer on that
without actually someone drilling down
into the into the data to see exactly
what those number seven ones are and
whether they are
um you know whether they're just
extremely complicated in the last three
months or they're just relatively
complicated in the last six months it's
uh it's a balance
um I mean
from your experience are there some
fairly uncomplicated cases that can
still use quite a lot of legal team time
it's not complexity isn't necessarily
directly proportional to the amount of
time that a a legal person has to spend
on the case
no it is a balance um
we've come up with this system which is
as simple as possible but given as much
information as possible at the same time
we could make it more complicated but
you're right there are a lot of matters
and you look from the numbers there's
very few complexity one matters yeah on
there and the main reason for that is
that quite a lot of them are just dealt
with with a single phone call or dealt
with in 10-15 minutes and don't even get
registered as a new instruction and they
they take that part of your day he can
take two or three calls like that in in
a day but
um
so yes I don't think we're ever going to
be able to have a be in a position where
we can guarantee both of them is suffer
going to get 50 of the time and we're
sometimes we get 50 of the time it's but
but it's something that has to be
reviewed and I'm sure will be and and if
there is any issues with on the cost
aspect like I say that's that's dealt
with at a top level between Council and
Council and I'm sure they will look at
the data and say well
the value you've had this is the this is
what you pay for that value
and if I might um chair the staff time
recording system allows for that to be
done in in quite some detail yes it's a
system it's called Norwell
um it's a system we've used from the
start
um of when we first became the shared
legal service back in 2017
um I believe it's actually up
um so so it may be up for review in the
next year or so but it but it's a system
that that's
um gives quite a lot of detail
um as to the the time you're spending
what you're spending
on that time
um so you're not you're not just
recording time for a particular matter
you're also telling the the system what
you're doing as well whether it's um
being at court being at meetings and
things like that um so so there is quite
a lot of detail contained with that
within that system
one last one then not a question
chairman but a suggestion
um I mean I do like pie charts but I
think actually for the purposes of
comparison
um we could do with only two charts
which actually showed the two Financial
years side by side in a bar chart form
and then it would easily address
councilor Willems issue in Denver
looking at it one in terms of I'm sure
we'll pass on the comments about
presentational skills to the to the
vehicle team thank you and if you don't
receive the Sounds in the post you'll be
all right
right this that report was for noting so
if nobody's got any more points thank
you very much indeed for your time
I'm sure it will be billed to us
accordingly
[Laughter]
on paper anyway
moving on to item 10 then on the agenda
recommendation from The Joint overview
and scrutiny task and finish group for
Rural transport
I work for the task and finish group has
been undertaken jointly however there
are separate recommendations to each
cabinet the debate and votes will be
taken separately for each committee
I would like to invite councilor Wenham
to introduce the report to the committee
he was set up as a task and finish Group
which first met in September 2021. and
it was clear early on that there are
areas within the districts both
districts where there is little or no
access to public transport
also that community Transport was being
provided to meet the needs of residents
of some parts of the district but not to
others
and also the community Transport weren't
really promoting themselves well enough
a lot of people didn't know that
community Transport existed or or what
services they could be requesting
there was a fair split between what the
way that the mid-suffer members felt
this could progress and the way that the
baby members
I felt it could progress and that was
that Gap was widened following a
decision by mid-suffolk to provide
electric mini buses to serve residents
of mid-suffolk District
so that it then became clear that we
would need separate recommendations to
the two separate cabinets
and that's the reason why we have on
page 39 the second the two sets of
recommendations
um
so thank you chair that's all I think I
need to say by way of introduction
in silence all right can we get the end
of the agenda
well
anybody got anything to say on the
debate side cancel it only only there
was anyone is anyone here from the um
other than
Keith is there anyone here from there
well perhaps my all right my question is
um
uh
what was the reason that that the baber
one doesn't want to do a survey of
residents I suppose
a student there's a mid-suffolk are
doing a survey of
of residents into in an urban and
asking for a
um to use the
evidence from
data the bus the community-based
companies
um
the the main reason is
um a financial one that
fairly bluntly baber haven't got any
money that they're recommending is put
into this
um
but mid-suffolk have already decided to
put money into the minibuses and all and
therefore into how best to use the money
buses
so that's the reason that it's
completely different across the two
districts between the two districts
well it occurs to me that we ought to
take a baber up to take a leaf out of
mid-suffolk's book and look into whether
we can find the money for a couple of
buses go around Sudbury
well I think the people of my my ward
and the parts of peninsula would have a
little bit to say about that because
they don't have any buses of any
description let alone electric one
taking them somewhere so I think it's
something that has to be looked at
separately by the two different councils
and looked at in the light of their own
environmental surroundings
so but uh um
I thought we were considering this as
two separate councils anyway so yeah so
my I suppose my recommendation to the
to the um
Baba cabinet
is that
you know we approve this for now but but
also investigate
affordability of supporting a sort of
hop a bus around our main town
is it possible to have that as a an
amendment
proposal from councilor Lindsay is part
of our recommendation you know there can
be some additional recommendations and
and I would uh I would uh definitely
endorse it but not just for a town but
for you know to look at the whole
district and how it can be done I think
it's it it's a
came quite clear that the Community
buses were not publicized very well by
county councils
and the service buses were becoming
increasingly
few and far between in their in their
service so it was a difficult time to
sort of match the two up together so
something that looks at it again would
obviously be a benefit to the to the
residents of the district yeah so you'd
like to propose that for the baber
recommendations
oh
did you get some wording on that Council
Lindsay would you mind just repeating
what you just said please
I think we leave 1.1 and 1.2 yeah
recommendations as they are yeah and
then 1.3 would be
um
that the paper overview and scrutiny
committee
um recommend to the cabinet
uh
that
the feasibility of uh
um
uh what's the word they use in the of a
bus
service we have an electric mini bus
well the scheme that we're talking about
yeah I mean as I understand it that goes
that sort of goes around stone Market
it's in the Stow market area I presume
it takes people the same market so yeah
the feasibility of of having
um providing a
Shopper bus
for the Sudbury area
so
I feed the bus service to to the yeah
yeah
so in domesticate to investigate the
feasibility of a did you say electric
bus project
uh similar to itself
um transport the buses terribly
overloaded dangerously if we could maybe
consult with Suffolk County Council and
education because that is a serious
problem because there's double the
amount of children on the school bus to
go to bury a college bus to go to bury
at the moment so if we could liaise with
Suffolk County Council know what you
think Derek
highlight the
potential for certain Services being
overloaded and other services not being
bloated to capacity so so get them
started looking but yeah
anything else for baber to to add on
that and if so we will take a a baber
vote on those recommendations before we
move on to uh the mid-suffic ones
nothing to add do you want to just read
those back again yes
so you have to
and then the third recommendation will
be that the baber
it's not correct
just give me two minutes Chad yeah
just right so that the joint overview
and scroogee committee recommends to
cabinet that the feasibility of
providing electric bus project
throughout the district similar to that
being implemented by mid-suffolk
is investigated
um
it's all right I'm just getting geared
up for the electronic boat
pigeon's going slow yeah
thank you Chad that vote is now in
progress for baby Members Only
Council agency might take you out
verbally please
hand over to Council of Wellington
thank you chair that is cool thanks for
all that is
conduct your
vote on your
because I need you to think that I was
telling you what to do
does anybody want to debate the issues
around our two recommendations
no can we go straight to the vote then
please
um
Council staff to propose cancer Carter
to second
and can the government's officer now
conduct the electronic vote please
thank you chair that work is now in
progress for mid-suffolk members only
Council staff may take your fate
verbally
thank you chair that's four votes for
that's unanimous
oh both those
proposals were accepted and will be
passed on to the appropriate cabinets
moving on then to item 11 overview and
scrutiny Committee Action tracker
remember to have any comments at all
yes
um so I think it's a great idea to have
the tracker I just wondered actually
what is the mechanism for actually
um
knowing that these actions have been
executed and completed
that's a good question
will attempt to answer that question I
will attempt to answer this question in
that
um in the uh chairs of the audience
scrutiny's um analog report uh very
often there is a section that implements
or indicates what happened to the
recommendations once they were
recommended to cabinet
and I see I have been scrutiny chairman
report the cabinet quite frequently
sorry to cancel quite frequently as well
there would be updated there of course
as well
I'm not sure that they do get reported
then at Council
Council worm will put me right if I'm
wrong
um if I may share I the re the reason
that
this was found to be necessary was that
there have been a number of occasions
when
this joint committee have recommended
various aspects of various different
matters to to cabinet and we haven't
heard back from cabinet
and so this is meant to be a checklist
which the officers keep up to date with
what happens to our recommendations to
cabinet or to council if their
recommendations to council
then they are included in our reports to
council if their recommendations to
cabinet in the past they have been
that'd be
well they've been getting lost to a
degree
um uh because what I didn't realize and
I I I don't think councilman McLaren
realized was that if we make a
recommendation to
um to cabinet and it's in in the in the
area of let's say community
Services then the uh the cabinet member
and the director are responsible for
seeing that that goes on to cabinet and
I don't think they realize that they
that was part of their responsibility so
um
so he was just getting lost
so this this means that we have a check
of what what's happening that was
particularly the case with
recommendations that we we made after
the scrutiny of citizens advice that we
heard nothing back at all
um from cabinet
on our recommendations we just had a
verbal report of a few words from a a
covenant member
the following year
that's not good enough and that's what
this is seeking to improve upon
so councilor Willem it seems to me that
if this is going to serve its purpose
fully
we need to close the loop by actually
having a feedback mechanism that says
what happened to the recommendation and
I don't think we should be waiting a
year to find that out no absolutely
that's what this that's what this seeks
to do and and this is on the the the
chairs and vice chairs meet with
officers every month prior to prior to
the next meeting so we've got a meeting
tomorrow which is going to be looking a
month ahead and this is on the agenda
for those meetings
sorry it's not now it's next Tuesday
isn't it
yes next Tuesday it's not on a Saturday
it's next Tuesday
but every every every month we we meet
and we go through
um the reports that are going to come
forward in the next month or two ahead
but also we look at the work plan and we
look at the track
so
between us the chairs and the officers
should be closing the loop and and
Reporting the closure of the loop to
this joint committee
so can I take it from that response that
come the next meeting if any of these
recommendations should have been
actioned and closed out that will be
reported then it should be yeah super
thank you
sorry I'll just
see if I can find an example there of
what's coming up at the next meeting
and there probably is one there but
we'll come to that later
um Right Moving on then to item 12
forthcoming decisions list
any comments at all
moving on again that's just that is that
list is for noting
paper and mid-suffolk overview and
scrutiny work plans first of all the
paper
work plan
any comments
labor members
no that's just for noting and
mid-suffolk
you know if I if I may
um we've noted in the mid-sufficient
work plan that most of the meetings are
joint meetings and they've got a
proposed date which is the the labor
date
um
that's I mean that's absolutely that's
absolutely fine I think that's
absolutely fine with us
but the two leaders have asked that
those dates be looked at because they
might clash with something that
that they might be doing on the odd
Monday
so I think that's something which which
officers have been tasked to do
um
my own personal view is that these are
formal meetings which have already been
put in the calendar and if there are
informal meetings which are taking place
then they shouldn't take precedence over
at our formal meetings but that's just a
personal View
if we can't have a formal calendar then
the whole system gets a bit crazy so on
the mid-suffolk one we have a joint
meeting on the 24th of October
um but
with an original date so are these is
the suggestion that we're moving it from
the 20th to the 24th yes
okay
um and all the way through with the
exception of
um the meeting which will look at
budgets because
um clearly like that they can't be that
can't be a joint meeting
this is thank you chair um just a couple
of comments I mean as one of the members
most affected by the date changes being
a mid-suffic member
it it sometimes makes it a clash with
another Council because many of us are
double headers or triple haters
um so if officers could always take that
interview as well that would be very
useful and to be able to have the list
of joint dates rather than continually
get cancellation of mid-suffer it's now
a joint plan we'd be really helpful in
advance so I I do welcome
the opportunity for us to actually fix
dates more accurately because it's not
it's not quite so easy for Midsouth
members to change dates by three or four
days sometimes and it sometimes means
that you're organizing
um
a
substitute potentially in your mind
because you've got another commitment
where you don't need to or that you
certainly do need to
we need to we need to um
sit down and organize a a finite
calendar for the meeting through the
year and without uh all the necessary
changes Etc really been going on
I'm sure the officers will be working on
that
do the call sir I mean I think
ultimately those calendars come before
full Council for approval yes I mean I
think it's it's understandable that
there may be changes from time to time
but I think we need to recognize that
quite a number of counselors have other
jobs
work jobs full-time jobs and
we plan around those calendars and it's
not always easy
possible yeah yeah so that people can
plan ahead
yes
I agree
um sorry chair the the one big unknown
is the the month in which the general
fund and the HRA
forward Outlook will be coming we were
we're working with Melissa to bring that
forward as soon as possible the members
will recall by the time we got it last
Financial year it was too late to do
anything other than
spend a long time looking at the
a PowerPoint
and we gain nothing from that so Melissa
is is very keen that we would we should
be given information about the process
and the assumptions
more at that end of the of the procedure
rather than the final numbers just
before they go to cabinet or just after
they've gone to Canada
I think that's most likely to be
November and most likely to well it will
then be a separate meeting
comments on